Hau mal dagegen ordentlich.
Nee, das mit der abgeflachten. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast UFO Pocket. Podcast! UFO Pocket! Wir sind heute in der Rockvariante. Man muss ja sagen, wir haben ja hier eine neue Firma gegründet und es läuft eigentlich auch ganz gut, aber in vielen Belangen auch nicht. Gewisse Dinge, wir mussten leider unser Podcast... Stichwort Infrastruktur. Wir haben unsere beiden Mikros abgegeben, sind das Teil einer großen grauen Masse, die der Firma gehört.
Großen Tentakel.
Habe ich nicht gefunden. Ich musste eben auch in so ein Techniklager gehen, wo ich mir unsere Sachen ausleihen musste und so ein Scheiß. Ich glaube, wir sind Mainstream geworden, wir sind jetzt zu professionell, wir sind nicht mehr der coole alte Garagen-Podcast. Aber irgendwie schon. Guck dir mal den Raum an, wir sind überall so Perücken und so ein Scheiß, das ist mega der creepy Raum. Und nebenan, wo ich das eben ausgeliehen habe, hatten die halt nur diese grossen Ständer, diese grossen drehbaren Ständer, das heißt, und die können wir, wir machen das nicht lächerlich, die sind nicht ensam am Tisch, und da haben die jetzt halt so Freddie Mercury-Style, haben wir einfach so einen grossen Mikrofonständer. vorne an denen jeweils so ein gitarrenartiger, grosses Konglomerat dranhängt und wir einfach in völlig dynamischer Pose stehen im Raum,
headbangen, weht durch die Gegend und nehmen diesen Podcast auf.
Man kann ja hier an der Stelle gleich mal ein bisschen Werbung machen, denn Stefan Tietzler und ich haben einen neuen Podcast gestartet diese Woche. Ich sag nur, Herr Rein. Oh, hallo, ich möchte euch diesen Podcast empfehlen. Die machen nur Improvisation, ist das nicht toll? Aber sie sind hier in einer Gärtnerei. Oh, aber dabei bin ich
doch ein Pilot und so geht das die ganze Zeit.
Die ganze Zeit nur Gäcks.
Habt ihr darauf Bock, zweieinhalb Stunden
diesen Level an Entertainment zu erfahren?
Dann tut dies mit unserem neuen Podcast
Gute Arbeit im Pro.
Um auf Soundcloud und auf iTunes
zu finden, abonnierbar, haut mal rein
und auch da alles, was ihr Patreon-technisch
an die spenden wolltet, einfach
auch direkt dem Podcast UFO zuführen,
dann glaube ich, kommen wir da auch auf
Vielen Dank. zu finden, abonnierbar, haut mal rein und auch da alles, was ihr Patreon-technisch an die spenden wolltet, einfach auch direkt dem Podcast-Ufo zuführen, dann glaube ich, kommen wir da auch auf Dönerich, Dönerich! Du hast eben geduscht, du hast eben im Klo angeschlossen, es kommt so ein ganz frischer Duft raus. Ja, es ist wirklich so, tagsüber mal duschen ist echt, ich dusche mich morgens, manchmal auch noch abends, aber tagsüber duschen ist nochmal so ein, wie so ein Nickerchen, fast bisschen, man ist noch mal neu und frisch, aber ich habe mit der weirdesten Dusche aller Zeiten geduscht, die drei Hebel hatte, einmal wie viel Wasser, dann keine Ahnung und dann noch mal, wo blau drauf stand, konnte man auf und zu drehen, aber ich habe es bis heute nicht verstanden, es war ganz, da wurden auch alle Gags schon drüber gemacht, über das, wenn man... Cool, dass du so in das Thema reingehst. Du bist da, um mich zu unterstützen. Okay, viel Spaß mit deiner... Das, was du gerade gesagt hast, ist natürlich völliger Quatsch. Aber ist doch wahr, dass über diese Heiss-Kalt-Mechanik, diesen ganzen wichtigen Drahtseilakt eines Lebens, jeden Tag, muss man das durchmachen. In die Richtung wollte ich gar nicht gehen, ehrlich gesagt, aber trotzdem danke, dass du den Schwierigkeitsgrad für mich erhebst. Viel Spaß mit der Anekdote, ich will nur mal einwerfen, dazu wurden alle Gags schon gemacht, aber viel Erfolg. Aber jetzt bin ich gespannt, ich werfe dir so Brocken hin, so Felsbrocken, die deine Gags zerstören. Aber das ist schon interessant, also ich frage mich auch, wie das läuft. Also du hast ja ein warmes Wassergerät in deiner Wohnung. Ich verstehe nicht. Und dann erstmal war es bei mir neulich mal im Arsch und dann ist es ja mit Gas und so. Ich habe dann sofort mega die Panik bekommen, weil wenn das kaputt ist und dann kommt da so ein rotes, so ein Warnzeichen und da habe ich diesen Heizmusmann angerufen und der meinte, man muss einfach da drauf drücken. Man muss einfach ein Tape drüber kleben über diese Lampe.
Man muss einfach ignorieren und dann gucken, was passiert. Aber das ist echt gruselig. Und wenn man da jetzt auf Warmwasser dreht, was passiert denn da mechanisch? Ich glaube, dann wird eine Leitung geöffnet. Also die Leitung teilt sich dann in so zwei, in so eine Y. Eine kalte Wasserleitung und eine Warmwasserleitung. und dadurch, wie du den aufdrehst, wird das Verhältnis, wie viel aus beiden Rohren genommen wird, verändert. Aber dafür ist es doch viel zu, dafür ist es eine einfache Erklärung, es ist viel zu schwierig, die richtige Temperatur zu finden. In meiner Dusche gibt es entweder nur unfassbar heiß, kochend heiß oder Antarktis. Ja, das Problem ist gar nicht Antarktis oder kochen, sondern mit der Dusche, in der ich es gerade zu tun hatte, gab es keine stabile Temperatur. Es gab nur kälter werdend und wärmer werdend. Das waren die beiden Einstellungen. Das heißt, du musst es eigentlich immer so wie so ein geübter Skifahrer, so links und rechts, dich immer so hin und her pendeln, um immer so in der Mitte zu sein und immer wenn es zu warm wird, dann wieder die Kurve einschlagen, sodass du auch so eine Temperaturslalomlinie dich dann so durch diesen Duschvorgang durchbimmelst. Ja, das Boosted Board hat Wellen geschlagen in der Community. Du hast viel zu viele Begriffe benutzt, die ich theoretisch hätte nutzen können für eine gute Überleitung, habe ich alle vergessen. Ich habe die Wellen schlagen, das hat mich alles abgelenkt. Mein Boosted-Board, darauf wollte ich hinaus, das ist schon richtig erkannt. Letzte Woche habe ich noch damit angegeben, dass ich mich zumindest weiterentwickelt habe, insofern, weil mein neues Gerät nicht explodiert. Falsch! Auch das neue Gerät, was ich mir anschaffen wollte für viel zu viel Geld, explodiert. Ist das nicht toll? Es ist grossartig, vor allem ist so der Inbegriff des Fehlkaufs eigentlich, Geld ausgeben für eine mässig spektakuläre Explosion. Die dich tötet im Idealfall. Aber wie ist der momentane Status, wie viel Prozent der Entscheidung hast du schon getroffen, dir dieses Boosted Board anzuleiben? Ich habe es mir auf jeden Fall gekauft schon, also der Kaufprozess ist bereits abgeschlossen. Ich dachte, du hast es nur reserviert. Ja, aber das ist schon, also es geht einher. Und das ist jetzt das Problem, weil die Lieferzeit so lang ist, weil das halt gerade erst rausgekommen ist, deswegen ist noch, also habe ich jetzt noch sehr viel Zeit, den Kauf zu bereuen. Moment, aber du kriegst jetzt definitiv dieses Boosted Board. Ich krieg auf jeden Fall das Boosted Board. Also wenn du jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie sturnierst oder sowas, kriegst du dieses Boosted-Board. Ja, wenn ich nicht mehr aktiv eingreife, also wenn ich mein Leben... Das wäre nur so ein Hirngespitz gewesen. Nö, wenn ich mein Leben gerade erhalte, genauso wie es ist, wenn ich nicht sterbe, wenn ich nicht bankrott gehe, wenn ich genau mein Leben erhalte und ich nichts ändere aktiv dagegen, bekomme ich mein Boosted-Board. Ihr seht schon, das wird ja hier ankommen wahrscheinlich, ne? Ne, habe ich extra nicht gemacht, weil ich vor diesem Gesicht Angst habe. Ich habe gesagt, ich bin erst mal zu Hause, in der Heimat, in der Eifel irgendwo, fahre ich erst mal ein paar Runden. Ja, vor allem da auf deinem Bürgersteig, du hast ja auch keinen Platz, um damit richtig zu fahren, du hast ja dann, aber gut, okay, ich will jetzt nicht zu viel verändern. Ich Ich bin im Moment im Highspeed-Modus. Ich habe mir jetzt auch neulich ein neues Playstation-Spiel gekauft. Manchmal habe ich solche Fahnen. Das ist ein Autorennspiel. Ja, ein Formel-1, Formel-1 2016. Das schnellste aller Autorennspiele. F1 2016. Das Problem ist aber, ich wollte einfach nur ein bisschen cruisen, so ein bisschen den Grand Prix von Japan schön von hinten aufrollen mal. Aber das Lustige ist, das ist mittlerweile so originalgetreu dieses Spiel, das habe ich noch nie erlebt. Du sitzt die ganze Zeit nur in einem Raum, wo Leute, du wartest eigentlich primär darauf, dass du fahren darfst. Und dann kriegst du es auch, das ist also so dermassen realistisch. Da kommt ein Typ zu dir und sagt dann, ja, ich bin hier Fahrzeugentwickler und ich habe hier einen Bericht und dann kriegst du so einen zehn Seiten langen Bericht, mega boring geschrieben einfach.
Und dann musst du den durchlesen, musst du durcharbeiten, dann musst du Forschung und Entwicklungsabteilung anrufen, dann kommt eine Agentin, die so Vertragsgedöns mit dem macht und so. Ich will ein bisschen fahren, Leute. Ja, ich will einfach nur fahren.
Das erste freie Training, dachte ich mir, okay, das kann man sich noch geben, um die Strecke kennenzulernen.
Das zweite freie Training, alles klar, langsam wird es lächerlich.
Das dritte freie Training, ernsthaft, Leute. Und dann irgendwann kommt das erste Qualifying und dann kommt tatsächlich das Rennen dann irgendwann. Aber da musst du auch noch eine Rennstrategie festlegen, Reifen festlegen und so ein Scheiß. Und dann fährst du auch die erste Runde, wie bei Formel 1, sehr will ich so, ist erstmal eine Einführungsrunde, um die Reifen warm zu fahren. Wo ich mir denke, Leute, die Reifen, die gibt's nicht, das ist virtuell, ich muss die nicht warm fahren. Du bist am Ende einfach so ein Profi, dass du einfach tatsächlich, sie können ja so auch in der Formel 1 fahren, sie sind wirklich Rennfahrer, es gibt keinen Unterschied mehr. Ja, ich glaube, ich habe auch so ein Rennen dann gewonnen, wo ich mir dachte, hmm, vielleicht kriege ich gleich einen Anruf und dann Bernie Eggleston ist am Apparat und gibt mir einen Job in der Formel 1. Er ist nicht mehr so weit weg. Ich habe früher auch tatsächlich Gran Turismo 5 viel gespielt und das ist auch sehr realistisch. Und da hieß dann irgendwann auch, dass du dann ein bisschen zu viel gefahren hast. Wo du deinen Nitro anmachst und dann wegfährst. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Gran Turismo, nicht Need for Speed, das ist schon realistisch. Wo ich dann irgendwann so Fehlermeldungen bekommen habe, sie haben zu viel Sand im Getriebe. Wo ich immer so diese Wüstenstrecken gefahren bin. Das ist eine Metapher für den Club. Geh mal wieder raus, die Naht. Einfach so, sie müssen ihr Getriebe ändern, weil da Sand risset. Da ging ich immer so diese Wüstenstrecken gefahren. Das ist eine Metapher für die Gruppe. Geh mal wieder raus, sie müssen ihr Getriebe ändern, weil da Sand risset. Nee, muss ich nicht. Einfach so, restart, neues Spiel starten, fickt euch einfach. Geh nach Hause, ich muss kein Sand aus meiner Getriebe. Ich bin auch ausgeschieden, im zweiten freien Training bin ich ausgeschieden und konnte dann das zweite freie Training in der Live-Übertragung, wie es im Fernsehen aussehen würde, wäre es eine echte Sache, gucken. Das ist echt so paradox. Du kannst deinen Gegnern dabei zuschauen, wie sie gewinnen, wenn du auf der Tribüne sitzt. Und zwar nur das zweite freie Training. Also ich kann nicht mal ein Rennen gucken. Ey, das ist so frustrierend irgendwann. Ey, du hast so ein frustrierendes Leben, immer so zwischen Stillstand und Highsby. Ja, selbst meine Freizeit ist auch immer mittlerweile noch frustrierend. Ich kaufe mir Formel 1, um Spaß zu haben. Nope. Ich kaufe mir das Boosted Board, um Spaß zu haben und nicht zu sterben. Tod. Ja, tot. Naja, schade. Ach Gott. Naja, aber machst du mal so einen Vlog auf deinem Boosted Board, dass dann wirklich auch die Leute so ein bisschen Gefühle für die Geschwindigkeit bekommen können, irgendwie? Ja, ich mache so eine vorne aufs Boosted-Board und dann mache ich ein YouTube-Channel ruhig jeden Tag. Machst du passen Apps. Auf jeden Fall, mein Mann. Machst du passen Apps. Auf jeden Fall. Wer Stefan noch nicht auf Snapchat folgt, könnte das tun unter? Ed Stefan Tietze. Nein, weil das ist ein Betrüger, den dürft ihr bitte nicht folgen. Das ist ein Hochstapler, der eben versucht, Identitätsdiebstahl zu betreiben. Ich bin Esteban Tithios. Esteban Tithios. Eigentlich geschrieben, wie man spricht. Aber bei dir, darauf müssen wir heute zu sprechen kommen, geht es steil bergab mit deinem körperlichen Äusseren. Um nicht zu sagen, mit deinen Haaren. Du verlierst, es ist ein paar Gerüchte jetzt im Umlauf.
Mich hat das über drei Ecken erreicht, dass ich jetzt plötzlich hinter der Hand als der neue Monty Burns gehandhabt habe, der jetzt irgendwie unter Haarverlust leidet.
An mich ist es gar nicht so weit geht. Nicht wegen den Haaren bist du als Monty Burns bezeichnet intern.
Das ist nicht wegen den Haaren.
Ach, hallo.
Hey, hallo.
Cool, ciao! Hey! Okay. Sondern ... Sondern wegen deinem fiesen Charakter. Was über drei Ecken hat sich erreicht ... Ja, dass man anscheinend jetzt hinter meinem Rücken munkelt, ich hätte Haarausfall und würde jetzt langsam auf die 40 zu gehen, präventiv. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das herkommt.
Ich finde, ich habe junges, scheckes Haar und
ja, manchmal der Blick in den Spiegel oder in ein paar Videos
aus einem ungünstigen Winkel. Es ist ja so,
als Medienstar, da legt
man sich ja auch mal wieder.
Die Alkoholstimme, genau.
Weißt du, der Unterschied zwischen mir und euch,
ihr seht euch manchmal im Spiegel oder auf
so einem Foto von einer langweiligen Hochzeit. Ich kenne mich ja von vorn und hinten, ja, also ich kenne mich ja in verschiedenen Situationen, von oben, von unten, manchmal, dann werfe ich mein Haar in die Kamera und dann sehe ich, schaue ich mir das an. Ich habe ein viel größeres Bewusstsein von meinem eigenen Körper, weil ich es ja überall an jeder Plakatwand. Deswegen macht es mich auch wahnsinnig fertig. Deswegen macht es mich fertig, ja. Du hast mich bei Tangen so geweint. Du saßt auch abends noch lange im Büro.
Da gab es recht scharfes Catering an dem Tag.
Und da gab es viele verschiedene Faktoren, die da ineinander gegriffen haben in dem Moment.
Und diese verschiedenen Haarmittel, die allerdings in unserem WC stehen. Ich habe letztens mit Simon und Lars auch bei einem Almost Daily bei den Rocket Beans über das Thema Haarausfall gesprochen.
Und die haben gesagt, es gibt ja, glaube ich, ganz viele Mittel. Das ist ja schon eine jahrhundertealte Industriehaarhaltung, aber das ist, glaube ich, alles Fake und alles Scharlatanerie, so wie in Red Dead Redemption, wo man dann irgendwelche Haarwasser verticken muss. Und zwar bringt es nicht, sobald die mal ausfallen. Haarmilch, wo man Haarmilch verticken muss. Kam ein bisschen zu spät, aber nicht schlecht, aber das Timing war schlecht. Aber man muss, und da gibt es so ein Mittel, das anscheinend auch gut funktioniert, aber das muss man nehmen, bevor einem die Haare ausfallen. Und das ist jetzt rein logisch so ein bisschen schwer zu timen. Also in der Woche, nehmen Sie das eine Woche, bevor Ihre Haare ausfallen. Das ist also, okay, mache ich. So, das ist schwierig und ich weiß nicht, ab wann für mich der Zeitpunkt gekommen ist, wo ich dieses Zeug nehmen soll oder kann. Dieses Präventive finde ich total interessant und zwar am meisten Film ist auch bei Vorherbildern von Meth-Abhängigen. Wann wurde das gemacht? Wann und in welcher Situation wurde das Vorherbild, wenn man bei Google eingibt, Meth-Addict, kommen immer verschiedene Bilder, die vorher und nachher eine blonde Frau zeigen, die irgendwann die Haare ausgefallen sind.
Aber in welcher Situation entsteht das Vorherbild? Ich glaube, das ist die Aufgabe eines verantwortungsvollen Drogendealers, der sagt, Math hier, erste Math, bevor Sie anfangen, stellen Sie sich nochmal ganz kurz an diese Wand da hinten. Ich mache ein kleines Foto. Ich glaube, es ist so der Ehepartner, der sagt, du, ich habe das Gefühl, in den nächsten paar Wochen wird es mit dir steil bergab gehen. Stell dich mal bitte vor diese Farben. Um dir dann zu zeigen zu können, wie steil bergab machen. Stell dich mal kurz vor eine farbneutale Wand und gucken mal, was passiert. Und Licht muss gleich sein und die Kleidung muss gleich sein. Finde ich mega interessant. Oder ist das alles Photoshop? Ich glaube, die nehmen einfach die Bilder von dem Abgenommen und drehen die einfach um und sagen dann einfach früher dünn und jetzt fett oder so, dann für irgendwie die Risiken von Pommes oder sowas.
Ich glaube, das wird einfach wild durchgeschachert. Ich habe, wo wir gerade bei Haaren waren, im Internet eine schockierende Meldung gelesen, und zwar, dass man konnte irgendwie so einen Test machen, welche Jobs, wie sehr dein Job vor der Zukunft gefährdet ist, wie groß die Chance ist, dass Roboter deinen Job machen können. Comedy-Autor war bei 100 Prozent die Chance, dass es irgendwann von Robotern gemacht wird, aber Friseur war bei null Prozent. Und da habe ich mir einen Tag vorher Gedanken darüber gemacht, weil ich zum Friseur musste und mir dachte, warum gibt es dafür nicht mittlerweile so wie so Fastfoodketten so Maschinen, wo man sich einfach reinsetzt, die deine Haare messen.
Du müssen nur, ich meine, das sind alles Köpfe, die sind ungefähr die gleiche Form, die können die kurz messen mit so einem Band und dann müssen die die Haardichte messen, die Haardicke messen und dann können die dir auch so Vorschläge machen, dann klickst du einfach drauf, was du für eine Frisur willst, kannst dir sogar noch einen Promi anklicken, wo du genau die Frisur haben willst oder so, der so Beispiele gibt, der dir noch anbietet, was für dir passt, weil er vorher alles ausgemessen hat, was dir stehen würde. Aber vielleicht ist ja die Akzeptanz nicht da, dass Leute keinen Bock haben, sich in eine Maschine mit so vielen wirbelnden Klingen zu setzen und da irgendwie den Maschinen zu vertrauen. Ich traue Menschen da viel weniger. Immer wenn ich mit dem Friseur bin und dann sage ich, ja, Nacken ausrasieren und so, denke ich mir, wenn ihr jetzt niest, dann sind alle Haare weg. Einfach dann so wups und dann einfach so querrullig. Wer hat das erzählt mit dem Rasierer, wo der Akku leer war? Das ist bei mir passiert, jede Woche.
Also, wenn ich, jede Woche, bei dem, ich weiß nicht, bis ich erzählt habe, aber bei mir ist es auch häufiger passiert. Irgendjemand hat das erzählt, dass er mal beim Friseur war und dann hat er so den Rasierer und dann hat er so angefangen, von links nach rechts durch zu rasieren und bei der Hälfte ging der Rasierer aus, war der Akku leer. Und dann hat der Friseur einfach gesagt, okay, fertig und hat den Spiegel gezeigt und man so, okay, danke.
Aber es war halt offensichtlich, dass er, war der Akku leer. Und dann hat der Friseur einfach gesagt, okay, fertig, und hat den Spiegel gezeigt und man so, okay, danke, aber es war halt
offensichtlich, dass der einfach nur der
Akku ausgegangen ist. Das fand ich auch so
skrupellos einfach, okay, fertig.
Aber bei dem Spiegel weiß ich schon vorher, was ich
sage. Bevor ich sehe, habe ich schon
in meinem Kopf zurechtgelegt, dass ich gleich sage, oh,
ja, gut, das ist aber schön.
Aber vor allem, es darf auch nicht zu früh kommen.
Man muss sich schon ein bisschen Zeit lassen,
so ein, hm, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
und dann, ja. Wie bei so einem
Wir haben eine sehr gute Idee, der in dem Moment exakt berechnen kann, welcher Winkel, lichteinfall, wo du in den Spiegel schaust, weil das ist ja, du musst es ja doppelt umkehren oder dreifach sogar. Das ist nämlich, ich habe mir nämlich mal so ein Zahnarztinstrument gekauft, fand ich total interessant.
Dieser kleine runde Spiegel.
Ich habe mir ein kleines Spiel gekauft und so diese Kratz-Pick-Kratz-Dingen.
Was stimmt mit dem nicht? Und dann wollte ich so meine Zähne von hinten anschauen und habe dann den Spiegel in meinen Mund gesteckt und habe dann geguckt, also habe in den Spiegel geschaut und den Spiegel in meinen Mund gehabt und habe es nicht auf die Reihe bekommen, den Spiegel so auszurichten, dass ich die und dann habe ich so Zwischen, so die Fü von unten gesehen, keine Ahnung wie das mal ging. Und dann habe ich geguckt und irgendwann habe ich das Spiel wieder weggelegt und habe nie wieder benutzt. Ein Großteil seiner Kindheit. Ich glaube ein Großteil unserer beider Kindheit bestand daraus, sich mega auf etwas zu freuen, auch von Leuten ausserhalb, so oh das klingt ganz cool, so abgefahren, aber relativ originell und dann aber massiv eingebrochen, immer jede Idee hat so fünf Minuten lang Enttäuschung mit sich gebracht und dann so ein Weglegen.
Und dann klappt es nicht und dann einfach, ja, brauche ich nicht mehr. Aber das war echt.
Ich habe auch so, ich habe jetzt nochmal Sachen auch noch unten im Keller, wo ich die ganzen, meine ganze Kindheit verstaut habe. Das ist so ein Paradies, da kann man wirklich, manchmal gehe ich einfach dann in meine Heimat, in den Keller und gucke diese Schränke durch. Ich finde das ein Paradies, das man da entdeckt. Was für ein Quatsch. Ich habe zwischenzeitlich mal diese Modellflugzeuge gesammelt, dann habe ich diese Gogos, kennst du noch Gogos? Das sind so kleine Figürchen, die je nachdem, wo sie stehen, eine gewisse Punktzahl erreichen, aber die sind so geformt, dass sie halt unterschiedlich stehen, das sind so kleine Monster. Kennt ihr noch Gogos da draußen? Das ist der grösste... Schreibt es in die Kommentare, wenn ihr euch noch an Gogos erinnert, schreibt es in die Kommentare. Ja, ja. Wenn ihr übrigens noch Kindergeschichten habt von euch, schickt ihr auch mal wieder ein, Leute. Wir machen mal wieder eine Kindergeschichten-Folge. Können wir auch mal wieder machen. Wo ist eigentlich unser Pionier-Dasein hin, mal auf solche Ideen zu kommen? Du hast mittlerweile vorgeschlagen, das Projekt komplett zu begraben, dir ist komplett alles scheißegal, du bist noch Patreon, du bist noch so pseudomässig, hast du gesagt, hast du angeboten, dass wir so bei Google-Stimme dich sprechen lassen und mich sprechen lassen und dann hast du gesagt, ja, dann können die die alle weiter spenden, aber dieses Projekt wird es nicht mehr zu tun haben. Ich habe lediglich die in meinen Augen interessante Frage gestellt, wenn wir jetzt aufhören zu veröffentlichen, wie lange dauert es, bis der letzte seine Patreon- Spende zurücknimmt? Weil das wird ja wöchentlich abgebucht und angenommen, wir hören jetzt auf, dann würden ja immer mehr Leute ihre Spenden. Können wir einen Patreon-Counter?
Irgendwann würde man einfach,
ich glaube auch noch in zwei Jahren, es sind immer noch fünf Leute da, die immer noch spenden. Uns hat auch einer geschrieben, dass er für eine gewisse Monatszeit uns spenden will, aber er es wahrscheinlich verchecken wird, das auszuschalten. Und wir sollten ihn daran erinnern, Hahaha, jup. Ja, klar, du verstehst es, wie man Leute motiviert.
Erinnert mich daran, euch kein Geld mehr zu geben.
Ja, alles klar, kein Ding. Nee, ach, Bussebot freue ich mich drauf. Und was auch relativ wichtig ist, dass ich endlich mal einen neuen MacBook bekomme. Ich habe dann auch die Keynote gesehen, wo die einen neuen MacBook vorgestellt haben. Und was wirklich seltsam war, ich habe dann telefoniert nebenbei, weil ich irgendwas telefonieren musste. und dann habe ich halt die Keynote, weil ich die viel lieber sehen wollte, als das Telefonat, was ich finden musste, und habe dann halt die Keynote gesehen mit Untertiteln, weil wenn man das ausmacht, bleiben ja die Untertitel stehen, die die ganze Zeit erklären, was gesagt wird, und dann hat sich das aber irgendwie aufgehangen, die Untertitel, und dann lief halt, wenn das Publikum reagiert, kommt das in eckigen Klammern, steht das dann da. Und da haben die gelacht, dann stand da Laughter. Und dann hat sie das aber da aufgehangen, aber unten, die Unterzeile, lief immer weiter. Das heißt, die ganze Zeit lief das, was gesagt wurde, aber oben oben stand immer Laughter. Und ich dachte mir, habe aber erst nicht verstanden, dass es angehalten hat, und dann dachte ich mir, Moment, ist das alles... Die lachen die halbe Keynote durch. Es bliebimmend ein ganzer Lafter und dann wurde da auch dein Macbook vorgestellt. Ich hab mich gefreut, Wahnsinn! Und dann dachte ich mir, hm, was ist denn da eigentlich gerade los in Kalifornien? Was geht denn da ab, Herr Wehr? Ja, und dann haben wir uns überlegt, dann kommt da diese neue Tastatur oben, wo man dann ... Die lachen sich kaputt. Und dann, als jemand, der sich mit Comedy auseinandersetzt, dachte ich mir, okay, die machen ja manchmal Witze auch. Dann habe ich angehalten, wo machen die denn jetzt den Gag? Ist das ironisch? Warum lachen die denn die an Zeigen? Das ist schon mega gut. Ja, und dann haben wir uns für 1299, könnte die die kleinste Variante kaufen. Oh mein Gott! Laughter, laughter, laughter! Ich glaube, da kann man auch so einen Sprecher komplett aus dem Konzept bringen, wenn du einfach auch durchlachst, einfach nicht mehr aufhörst. Ja. Gar nicht unpassend lachst, sondern einfach nicht mehr aufhörst. Laughter, laughter. Leute, Leute, komm runter. Danke, aber ruhig kommt mal ein bisschen runter. Irgendwann dachte ich dann so, in meinem dummen, naiven Hirn, was noch nicht in der Lage war zu verstehen, dass es angehalten hat einfach, dachte ich dann irgendwann, dass sie sich so freuen über das neue MacBook, dass sie durchgehen lassen. Emotionen nicht anders ausdrücken können als so eine zu spitzte Form der Freude, einfach nur. Das fand ich so gut. Aber wurde es nicht live übertragen? Ja. Haben wir dann live untertitelt oder was? Wie? Steno. Steno. Steno. Das ist völlig selbstverständlich. Steno. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie das funktioniert eigentlich. Der hat wirklich jemand eins zu eins live mitgekippt. Ich glaube ja auch ein bisschen, dass es geskriptet ist, erstens. Zweitens bilden sich aber auch Wörter für Wörter nacheinander. Das heißt, ich glaube wirklich, dass da jemand sitzt, so Protokollantinnen, wie auch diese Stenografinnen aus dem, da sind auch Stenografin, mein Gott, die dann da im Bundestag sitzen und das Mitschreiben, die ganze Sitzung, die müssen die auch in Echtzeit machen. Ob das in Echtzeit auf dem Papier entsteht, ob im Echtzeit digital ins Internet geschossen wird. Aber die haben ja keine richtige Tastatur, die haben wie so eine kleine Orgel, so Stenografen. Die haben einen Stenografen vor sich liegen. Das ist eine Apparatur, wo man auch verschiedene Sachen mitmachen kann, unter anderem zur Arbeit fahren, man kann darauf surfen, tosten. Aber die haben so mehrere Ebenen, also so mehrere Ebenen wie so ein Keyboard, aber es gibt ja diese Keyboards mit mehreren Etagen, wo die dann übereinander sind. Und das haben die auch, aber halt so eher so vier, vier mal vier oder so. Sodass man da wirklich so wie so seine Hände so reinkneten kann in diese Tastatur und dann so da drin ist, glaube ich. Haben wir aber mal gesprochen über die, über chinesische Schriftzeichen versus Emojis, dass ja eigentlich Emojis nichts anderes sind als. Ja, das kann sein. Und stell dir mal vor, haben die in China auch ein Sonnen-Emoji, weil das macht ja keinen Sinn, weil die haben auch ein Sonnen-Schriftzeichen. So, und dann irgendwann gibt's, also das ist doch so ein Perpetuum mobile, also. Ja, dass sie die dann irgendwann integrieren oder was? Ja. Könnten die mit Emojis Texte erzählen, würde mich mal interessieren. Weil alte Schriftzeichen sind ja auch nichts anderes als einfach nur quasi Wortzeichen. Also genau wie Emojis. Aber ich glaube, ganz so ist es nicht. Ich glaube, das sind schon eher so Silben oder so Bedeutungen, dass es dann irgendwas wie hell heißt oder so, aber nicht Sonne im Weite kann es ja nicht für jedes Wort ein eigenes Erschwasschen.
Also ich finde das so kontraintuitiv. Ich habe auch mal gedacht, Aliens sehen wahrscheinlich genauso aus wie wir, die schreiben ähnlich wie wir, die haben ähnliche, halt möglichst einfach simplifizierte Nummern und Zeichen und Wörter halt mit einer begrenzten Strichanzahl. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, es gibt halt auch Chinesisch so, das ist einfach das Letzte, an was man denken würde. Das ist so weit weg von allem. Chinesische Schriftzeichen, möglichst viele, möglichst lange. Wir brauchen, also, überlegt euch mal was, es soll möglichst unpartisch und möglichst lange dauern. Ja, machen wir ... Ja. Hast du denn gerade einen Gag abgebrochen? Nee. Komm, lass die Gags. Ich habe mir überlegt, dass es relativ einheitlich ist, unsere Sprache und so, hängt damit zusammen, dass es mal grosse Imperien und Reiche gab. Und die gesagt haben, wir machen alles gleich. So römisches Imperium, dann, wir machen jetzt Meile und so und wir bauen Strassen jetzt gerade, ja, oh mein Gott, die alten Befindungen jetzt wieder. Wir hätten so Loopings überlegt, nee, das machen wir gerade. Immer so S-Form, nee, mach gerade, Alter. Diese Diskussion gab. Wirklich nicht so zickzack, nee, Alter, Plombombus, wir machen jetzt gerade. Und wir wollen Rat, nicht diese Vierecke, die du vorgeschlagen hast, Bäffern. Nicht diese Sternchen, die so aussehen wie so ein Paragraphenzeichen. Wir machen einen Kreis, ihr Trottel. Einfach so, okay. So ein geilen Gag, dass man vor der Erfindung des Rades auf so Vierecken rumgefahren ist. Und die kutschen die ganze Zeit so. So ein Herzzeichen. Ach nein, jedes Mal. Ja, und die Frage ist, ob es ab jetzt in Zukunft wieder große Reiche geben wird, oder ob die Unterschiede jetzt einfach bestehen bleiben. Oder ob man einfach mal sagt so, hey, eine Macht übernimmt die ganze Welt und sagt dann, jetzt machen wir hier Celsius und Kilometer und wir fahren alle rechts. Dann und dann zerbricht das Reich wieder, aber dann ist es ja schon mal getan. Dann ist ja das schon mal geleistet und dann ist es für den Rest der Geschichte zumindest mal einheitlich. Ich habe auch früher als Kind oft nicht verstanden, dass man sagt, drehe dich mal um 180 Grad, dass es nicht mit Temperatur zu tun hat. Das war für mich unvorstellbar. Und dann dachte ich mir, was soll ich tun? Was soll ich jetzt machen? Was verlangst du von mir, Mutter? Was verlangt es dir, Martha? Moder? Was ist das denn mit dem Kind eigentlich? Er hat schon wieder so komisch reagiert heute. Können wir den mal untersuchen lassen? Sechsjähriger Junge. Was verlangt es euch, Martha Paterque? Stefan war schon immer ein merkwürdiger Junge. Zum Talking Head. Ja, Stefan, das war schon immer ein merkwürdiges Kind. Merkwürdiges. Irgendwie hat er sich auch nicht so zurechtgefunden mit seinen Artgenossen im Kindergarten. Hm? Was fleucht euch, Martha? Was dünkt es euch, Frau Gerling? Ich solle die Lego-Sachen weglegen? Ja, aber da füllen wir jetzt nicht mehr ein, was man dazu sagt. Passt schon, passt schon, passt schon. Okay. Kindergarten, Thema Kindergarten. Au ja. Was war das Wertvollste in deinem Kindergarten? Ich glaube, das ist ein Paradoxon, das ist nicht unmöglich, das ist ein Oxymoron. Ja, aber das Wertvollste, was ist der wertvollste Gegenstand in deinem Kindergarten? Ich glaube, die Klingel von Halligalli, weil die ist so silbrig. Das stimmt schon, ja. Die ist so silbrig. Man könnte sagen, metallisch quasi. Das lohnt sich, die mal zwischen die Bisschen. Es gibt, selbst das Besteck ist ja aus Plastik und so. Ich meine, alles, was im Kindergarten ist, darf per se keinen Wert haben, weil es irgendwann mal zerstört werden könnte. Und wird. Also alles, was im Kindergarten passieren kann, das ist Murphy's Law.
Das ist dann so, unser Kaninchen hat in die Legosteine gepinkelt und weg damit,
einfach nächste Tüte aufgerissen.
Meinst du Legosteine oder das Kaninchen, weg damit?
Beides. Beides weg.
Komm, was soll denn der Geiz?
Aber war es bei euch nicht auch so, bei uns war es so, dass wir
so ein Kaninchen hatten und dann wollten
wir aber viel lieber eine Katze haben
und dann hat die Betreuerin gesagt, naja, aber ein, wir können nicht zwei Haustiere haben, eins reicht und dann haben wir dieses Kaninchen in so die Ecke getrieben und dann so draufgetreten und dann so ein bisschen gestorben und dann... Was? Nein, stimmt nicht. War nur ein Gag. Aber ich habe mir kurz überlegt, dass Kinder meinen, alles was ihnen helfen könnte, dass sie es aus dem Lego bauen können.
Ich habe kurz gedacht, wie wäre es denn, wenn ihr so ein gross Schwert oder so eine Schlachtanlage aus Lego gebaut habt. Das ist eigentlich mega genial. Aber das ist tatsächlich, glaube ich, der Übergang von Lego. Bitte was? Mega erschrocken. Drama im Podcast. Weil irgendwann, dass man anfängt, realistisch große Gegenstände zu bauen. Ich habe nämlich auch irgendwann angefangen, meine Brüder haben das auch gemacht, so Schwerter und Gewehre und Pistolen auszulegen, in Originalgrößen zu bauen und die dann zu benutzen. Ich glaube, dann merkst du, da bist du erwachsen. Wenn du nicht mehr irgendwie kleine Flugzeiten nachher bist du kennst. Wenn dein Lego-Raumschiff die Größe deines Hauses hat, dann bist du erwachsen. Naja, wenn du nicht mehr in der Fantasiewelt lebst, sondern wenn du versuchst, mit den Legos deine echte Welt zu rekonstruieren. Zum Beispiel auch bei der Kindertagesstätte, wo ich gearbeitet habe mit Kindern, gab es auch viel Lego und da habe ich immer so echte Sachen gebaut, so eine Blume oder so. Hast du auf die Kinder aufgepasst oder hast du deine eigene Agenda auf dem Schirm gehabt? Ich habe nur versucht, da die Haustiere zu erwirken. Aber bist du morgen zur Arbeit gegangen und hast gesagt, okay, heute muss ich dem Tim mal beibringen, wie er mit Frau Meier spricht? Oder bist du sagen, ich muss mein Lego-Projekt vollenden? So weit ging es nicht. Ich würde versuchen, wäre geil, wenn er heute nicht weniger als ein Kilo Erde isst. Das wäre schon mal ein Vorschritt. Das war schon der Level der Kinder da. Also da waren schon andere Ziele nötig. Ich habe immer immer ganz gern Jugemolz. Ich habe mal Gras gegessen, also immer so richtig reingebissen einfach, herzhaft. Also vom Boden, also bist du auch vom Boden gegangen und hast wie eine Kuh ins Gras gebissen und hast du erst abgerupft und dann gegessen. Nope. Ins Gras gebissen. Ins Gras gebissen, sprichwörtlich. Einfach um zu probieren, wie das so aussieht. Weil Kühe machen das auch und die leben ein tolles Leben, ein tolles Kuhleben halt. Da dachte ich mir, ich bin gerne in andere Rollen geschlüpft. Das war interessant, weil wir haben auch manchmal so Ausflüge gemacht und so eine Woche lang in so einer Herberge geblieben und so. Und da gab es ein Mädchen, ich habe mich auch immer mit dem Psychologen unterhalten, mit dem Kinderpsychologen, und der meinte aber, ein Mädchen hätte einen ganz starken Drang dazu, dass wenn sie nicht unter autoritärer Beobachtung ist, dann bewusst alle Regeln zu brechen. Also wenn gerade niemand hinguckt, dass sie dann bewusst alles macht, was sie nicht machen darf. Auch wenn sie das gar nicht unbedingt will, aber einfach nur, um es jetzt anders zu machen. Und da war es dann auch so, da waren wir auch so im Kinderspielplatz und dann so, ja geht mal da spielen. Und das Mädchen ist sofort auf die Rutsche gegangen und ist rückwärts auf dem Rücken die Rutsche runtergerutscht. Die Rutsche hochgerutscht. Wahnsinn. Ich breche auch die Regeln der Physik. Fuck you, Authority. Ja, aber einfach nur, um es anders zu machen. Fuck you, einfach rückwärts runter. Sie fällt den Baum hoch. Fuck you, Physics. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Ich breche alle Regeln. Diese Kinder, das ist auch immer, dass sie alle Regeln brechen müssen. Gegen die Schwerkraft einfach. Bei der ersten Staffel Dödelf hatten wir Frank Elstner da. Und dann hat er gesagt, er hat uns erlaubt, beim Kostüm wirklich alle Regeln zu brechen. Hat dann gesagt, ja, ihr könnt mit mir alles machen. Alles, ihr könnt alle Regeln brechen. zieht mir ruhig eine Lederhose an. Und das war das Schlimmste, was Frank Elstner eingefallen ist, was er tragen könnte. Der größtmögliche Regelbruch. Ja, wo ich mir auch denke, wenn so ein Kind so eine Krankheit hat, aber eigentlich so mega beschränkt ist und ungegiblich ist in ihrem Lebensraum, dass er dann so seltsame Sachen macht, wie die Rücktrüche rückwärts runterrutscht. Aber ich stelle mir so vor, wie sie dann auf die Rutsche klettert und dann so davorsteht und dann so denkt so, hm, was kann ich tun? Normalerweise rutscht man sitzend so und dann umgekehrt, doppelt umgekehrt. Und springt sie von der anderen Seite runter. Und ich ziehe meine Hose auf den Kopf und meine Jacke unten und einfach so immer alles anders machen. Sie muss noch nicht mal rutschen, also um alle Regeln zu brechen, kann sie auch diese Rutschaktion sein lassen. Sie kann ja auch an Ordnung stellen, du kannst so viele Regeln brechen, beim Kopf würde platzen. Aber Kopf platzen ist ein guter Stichpunkt, weil das Kaninchen, das wir dabei hatten, das nein, und zwar zum Thema Kopf platzen, was immer sehr lustig ist, war Gegenteiltag. Wenn die Kinder dich nerven, sag einfach, es ist Gegenteiltag, da haben die erstens Bock drauf, aber irgendwann fangen die an, sich in so viele Widersprüche zu verstricken, dass sie einfach passiv werden, einfach lethargisch umfallen. Wie so System Error. Ganz apathisch in der Ecke sitzen. Weil dann sagen die dann, ja, aber Moment mal, wenn heute Gegenteiltag ist, dann müsste doch Luft dich einatmen. Und das Kind so, ja, hört auf zu atmen, stirbt. Du hast die ganze rote Gruppe, ist jetzt tot. Und dann geht ihr mit dem Ball spielen und dann, nee, nee, der Ball muss doch mit dir spielen. Und dann, ja stimmt, und dann legt die sich passiv neben den Ball und nichts geschieht. Ich hasse gegen deinen Rack. Einfach, der Algorithmus hängt, er dreht sich im Kreis, da passiert nichts mehr. Und dann steht sie auf und muss eingestehen, dass es nicht funktioniert, die Regeln zu brechen. Das ist dann schon immer sehr, sehr interessant. Mit Kindern arbeiten das das Grösste, diese kleinen beschränkten Kacke hier. Ja, die sind wie so kleine Dinge. Wie so kleine Dinge, die sich verentwickelt sind. Man einfach so aufzieht und dann in Richtung Comedy schickt und sie immer delivern immer. Ja. Du weißt, die delivern einfach. Das ist schon ganz gut. Ja, ach Kindergarten, auch nicht so schlecht. Du, Luke Mochrisch macht ganz viel im Kindergarten, er macht ganz viele lustige Aktionen mit dem Fuchtiger. Du dumme Rübe! Das war immer das Lustigste, das eine Mädchen ist immer, wo ich dann in die, wo ich dann in die Gruppe komme, ja, wir haben da die Lea, die ist immer sehr intensiv mit Schimpfworten, also die ist sehr aggressiv und auch verbal sehr aggressiv und dann kommst du da rein und sagst, hey Servus, was geht denn so, du dumme Rübe! Und denkst dir so, wow, alter, Lea, du kannst nicht einfach dumme Rübe zu sagen. Und du musst dann so tun, als wären das so mega schlimme Begriffe, aber sind es halt gar nicht, irgendwie so, du Esel! Und ich so, hey, alter, Lea, da fick dich, das kannst du nicht machen. Bei uns hat einer mal in der gelben Gruppe, oh, die gelbe. Hat einer den anderen ins Ohr geschnitten mit so einer Schere. Oh nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, keine Scheren, sorry, keine, oh, sorry, ich habe es ganz kurz bestätigt. Alter, Schiffball. Hat ihn ins Ohr geschnitten mit einem Messer. Ja. Okay, und seitdem hat ihn auch irgendwie jeder mit so ganz anderen Augen gesehen. Mit ausgestochenen Augen. Irgendwie war das dann, das ist ja so eine Parallelgesellschaft. So ein Kindergarten ist ja so eine ganz, ganz fiese Parallelgesellschaft, wo man dann halt irgendwie auch so Menschen ins Aus, ins Abseits mobbt und ins Abseits stellt. Auch zur eigenen Sicherheit. Alle haben den nur noch gesehen, es ging auch so das Gerücht rum in diesen drei Räumen, in denen der Kindergarten gross war, dass da jemand was gemacht haben könnte. Es war so eine ganz seltsame Parallelgesellschaft, aber man hat ihn mit ganz anderen Augen gesehen. Das war der böse Erik, der den Leuten leib schneidet. Es gab auch immer Leute, der Leute gebissen hat. In jeder Gruppe gibt es einen Beisser, aber das ist so seltsam, weil das so eine seltsame Struktur ist. Und so ganz etwas ganz Natürliches, aber so abnatürlich. Ja, aber vor allem in jeder Gruppe gibt es einen Beisser. Ja, das stimmt. Wenn der kleine Jonas kommt in die Gruppe und fragt so, hey Leute, wer ist bei euch der Beisser und sagt, nee, wir haben keinen Beisser, dann wiesst du durch so ein Level-Up, wird automatisch einer zum Beisser. Das ist so eine Struktur einfach. Sobald der die Gruppe verlässt, der gibt es auch weiter. Okay, was gibt es? Es gibt den Beisser, es gibt den Schläfer, den Schläger, es gibt den Nudisten, es gibt den Treter, es gibt den Nudisten, es gibt den Ohne-Pätze. Oh, die Petze. Es gibt den Renner, der die ganze Zeit nur am Rumrennen ist, es gibt den Bauer, den Ingenieur. Der Träumer. Auch den Träumer, Träumerle. Ich war eher ein Träumer, glaube ich. Ich habe sehr viel geschlafen, immer im Kindergarten, habe immer viel, aber ein Sonnenschein war ich auch, wurde mir gesagt, ein Sonnenschein, habe immer viel gelacht. Hattet ihr auch an euren Garderoben so kleine Symbole, die euch, wo ihr merken konntet, was eure Garderoben, was hattest du hier, ein Schneemann, was habt ihr noch? Ich weiß nicht mehr, irgendwas grünes, Frosch oder so, glaube ich, aber ich war in der Igelgruppe, es gab die Dinosaurier, die Drachen und die Igel. Ich meine, Igel. Wow. Oh, die Schild passt auch. Aber gab es dann auch so manchmal so Lobbyisten, die versucht haben, die sich für eine Namenssendung eingesetzt haben oder so, okay, dann sind wir halt die Monster oder so. Ja, ich glaube, da gab es schon mal manchmal ernsthafte Diskussionen, aber am Ende ist es Fickt euch, geht wir nicht. Und ich gehöre auf Papier zu essen, das war das grössere Problem eigentlich, dass das Papier so, kann ich noch Mandala ausleihen und ausmalen, ja bitte und gegessen einfach. Aber du kannst den Kindern ja auch schlechtes Papier verwehren, wenn die sagen, ich will malen. Esspapier ist die einfachste Lösung. Ja, aber da malen die dann mit Enning drauf und malen dann irgendein Essen Nassau drauf. Aber warum gibt es S-Papier, aber nicht S-Laptops? Also warum hat man sich entschieden, bei Papier ist die einfachste Lösung. Ja, aber da malen die dann mit Enning drauf und malen dann irgendeinen Ess-Nassang auf. Aber warum gibt es Esspapier, aber nicht Esslaptops? Also warum hat man sich entschieden, bei Papier zu sagen, das wollen wir essen? Esspapier hat die digitale Revolution überhaupt nicht miterlebt. Was ist denn Menschen los, dass sie sagen, Papier, wir brauchen was, dass wir es auch essen können, aber alles andere, we don't give a shit, aber Papier, Esspapier, das wäre cool. Warum hat man da aufgehört, das ist seltsam. Esskissen, habe ich noch nicht gesehen, Esspappe, hm. Rassen wir das. Rassen wir das Mittelalter, dann Espergament und so, dann Esspapyrus, die früheren Varianten. Ja, nicht schlecht. Essteintafel, wenn wir uns beide eifrig anlegen. Ja, das ist eine gute Idee. Ja, Schulterklopfen. Ja, ach, ich bin durch. Du musst auch jetzt los. Ich muss schon langsam los. Ansonsten, Stefan Titzel, freut euch. Wann hast du eine ungefähre Ahnung, wann das Boosted Board kommt? Nein, leider nein. Da steht überhaupt kein Datum dabei, nicht mal ansatzweise. Du, ich bin irgendwann Ende des Jahres bei den Rocket Beans am Start, da kann ich es mitbringen, wenn ich es schon habe.
Cool, freut euch darauf.
Da fahre ich da durchs Studio.
Lasst die Rocket Beans Foren heißlaufen, Stefan Tietze hat sich angekündigt für die unbekannte Zukunft.
Alles klar, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao, wie!